yeah coming up your life and comic-con
with two of my favorite most magical
stars from the magician's hola
here we are back at comic-con bunny free
this time no bunnies no bunnies but you
and I I'm gonna chat we don't need a
bunny to be our mediator true last
season had everything musical episodes
alternate universes fairies bunnies how
do you feel about how it ended what was
your initial reaction to that shocking
cliffhanger disappointed no but like
what do you think about it especially
for her Julia she okay first of all the
sparkly goddess look was amazing do you
wish that jewels had held on to her
divine powers a little bit longer yeah I
mean I wish I wish there was a way for
her to help the greater good and not
have to give up being a god you know
kind of yeah just God well and you guys
know how much I absolutely adore Olivia
we gotta be real alice was kind of the
worst in the finale I don't know what we
did to deserve that I thought we had
been like yeah from the dead basically I
saved that girl's life like 30 times
yeah it's ridiculous
Julia gave her her magic yes back but
yeah but I helped her it was like I was
like miyagi ngering her and huh wax on
wax off Daniels that but so so now magic
is back in small doses but you guys do
not remember it at all when you found
out that basically you guys had your
memories wiped what was your initial
reaction
and it's not even shocked because at
this point I think we're like we ran or
almost like in mute like it's like you
can't you can't scar us you know you
can't scare this we've been hurt a show
and you need to have these giant hurdles
and in this case it's now just getting
their memories back together but is it
bad that I just missed the days of
learning magic at brakebills no I think
there should be more magic on the show
yes I think there should be magician
we're changing the title it's just sort
of like the folks the people I said the
civilians oh yeah yeah yeah the people
the people mm-hmm just some just some
people yeah but you didn't get to one of
the things that I love so much about the
show is the intricacies of the way you
guys do the spells and the different
hand choreography do you guys remember a
spell it's been a little while since
yeah yeah figured one out it's one of
those things it's like learning lines
like as soon as we finish a scene like
all cut every line is gone because I hey
I have to learn the next one and it's
sort of like this same with with the
tutting it's like I and I have these
like weird sausage fingers and they're
just like they just don't have a memory
yeah but yeah yeah but I think summer
had to learn a foreign late I know I had
to do a lot of Latin throughout the show
not not this season yet but I know
summer had to do I forget what it was
she was learning it the other day when
we were on set I forget what language it
was Estonian or something oh wow so
there's a little bit of that going on I
can handle it though let's be real
that's funny too she can do it she's
crazy
it's she has secret powers it's it's
amazing watching summer you play in
different languages
no no not since season one yeah
I I think I must have done it so poorly
[Laughter]
a few musical moments and then we got
the full-on musical episode yeah there'd
be more music in the season ahead they
keep threatening that yeah we haven't we
haven't read it or seen it yet and we're
only on Episode four so there's time yes
I still can't get over your Taylor Swift
man sock that's still forever my
favorite it it was probably one of the
coolest things that's ever happened to
me like I got to be a pop star for a day
I went into like this studio you know
with like I've got the things on and
there's glass and then there's other
people and there's like musicians
playing music and I'm and I'm like also
Jason think bad talk about your awesome
shirt because it is for a very important
cause for the fans who are watching
right now please Phil listen yeah so
Stella and I are coming out yeah we're
teaming up today we're trying to raise
$10,000 for the Covenant House which is
an international homeless youth shelter
they do a tremendous job of getting kids
off the streets but in awesome providing
them with the resources to stay off the
streets it's a phenomenal organization
we're doing what they call a sleep out
so we're gonna raise the money and then
we're they hold an event at the Covenant
house in New York and then everyone
who's a part of it sleeps on the streets
sort of in solidarity so we'll be on the
street so the kids don't have to be
hoping to raise $10,000 today so if you
see this shirt if you donate $5 we can
get there really easily so five bucks a
person yeah could do it we could do it
we can all do it especially um because
there are links in the BIOS so you guys
can just click it and I'm new to this
but I wanna I wanted to team up with
Jason before I went solo and I just feel
like together we can we could like
really make a difference and be really
cool yeah well the fans love the two of
you guys together and they're still
rootin
Julia and Quinton she maybe one day
actually become more than friends
thoughts on that
whoa I'm secretly like I'm like come on
man it's possible yeah yeah I think
there's like a well I think for Quinton
especially early on that was like a a
hope that it might go that way but then
she was dating Ted no she wasn't dating
something she got kicked out that she
didn't get in - brakebills yeah yeah
Chad James James his name would have
been John Doe yeah more like a chance
would be a chance like a Blaine I'm so
sorry
sad sad Brad yeah baby yeah rad bad Chad
yeah yeah can you tease for the next
season premiere for the fans I know you
know things but yet we don't we have
these are brand new characters it's a
brand new show yeah we you'll I spend a
lot of it covered in blood so alright
and I dress the hair until I'm gonna we
don't know episode 3 yeah good to know
well thank you guys so much for this
magical chat thank you appreciate it I
hope you have an enchanting comic-con
we'll see how many more spellbinding
words I can put into the rest of this
interview thank you guys the one love
you soon thank you so long
[Music]
[Music]